hello and welcome to the new world
review your source for all things anime
and manga today we're going to have a
bit of an angel discussion about the
rise and fall of one of the most
notorious modern czernin series bleach
and I'd like to go into this because
this may seem like a crazy notion today
but there was a time when bleach was at
the pinnacle of the Shonan world it
stood proudly beside one piece and
naruto as the big three and whatever
your feelings are regarding those other
two series there is no denying their
pure dominance of the manga and anime
medium during the glory days well
they're quite notably the glory days for
one piece are still continuing to this
very day but that's not what this video
was about during its time bleach was
fresh sleek and seemingly more mature
than its contemporaries with a less
cartoonish art style into somewhat
darker story premise making it stand out
and it caught the attention of the world
but with all eyes on this prolific
series how did it all go so horrendously
wrong well Before we jump into that I'd
like to state at the outset that I am
NOT here to bash Bleach it's a very
popular thing to do in the anime and
manga community to just call something
trash and refused to explain why beyond
a few simple talking points but I'm not
going to do that because bleach isn't
trash at worst it is a painfully average
Shonen but in its best moments it is an
incredible piece of storytelling it's
just that the former tends to do very
much outweigh at the latter I'm also
going to state right here and now that I
have not read or watched bleach to its
completion I completely gave up on the
series while the hueco mundo Ark was
being published in Weekly Shonen Jump
and I've tried to get back into the
series on many many occasions over the
past decade or so and it's just been
unable to hold my attention however I
don't think that not knowing the full
scope of Bleach puts me at a major
disadvantage in fact I'd say that I
represents a large majority of people
who conducted a mass exodus of the
series and have never looked back since
because it really does not take a bleach
scholar to identify the exact point in
which the series took a swift nosedive
into the cold harsh ground of mediocrity
I'm going to put this out there now that
moment was right here that's right after
the climax of the soul society arc the
revelation of Ison's villainy and
subsequent complete dismissal of our
protagonist Ichigo with a single finger
in context this moment is pretty
phenomenal it's a huge oh damn situation
and builds a hell of a lot of hype but
in retrospect this is both arguably one
of the greatest moments in the series as
well as the very thing that destroyed it
and I want you to keep this in mind
because we'll be referring back to it
frequently as it ties in with all of
glitches major issues being characters
world and narrative also known as the
Holy Trinity of storyteller
and sad they each and every one of which
would be thrown under the bus by this
series so let's take a look at
characters first and there are no better
eyes to look at this issue through than
the man himself Ichigo Kurosaki now when
I was a teenager
Ichigo held a lot of Appeal to me
because he was portrayed as an angry a
pathetic creature much like myself at
the time but deep down he held two moral
compass that compelled him to act
usually in order to protect someone or
something however what Ichigo was very
much missing is something that is
essential to almost all major Shonen
protagonists which is a desire for
example monkey day luffy desires to
become the fired king Naruto's dream is
to become the Hokage and even in taka
series this ambition is still present
like in Death Note
where light has a very clear goal of
ridding the world of evil which becomes
incredibly twisted in the process but
that goal is his driving force at all
times now tell me what is it she goes
goal dream or desire the answer is
nothing
Ichigo could more accurately be
described as a character with zero
ambition whatsoever who becomes
incidentally involved in a series of
ever escalating conflicts because his
friends and/or family are at risk
he is a passive protagonist meaning that
each go only have a response to stimulus
he does not initiate and as a result
following his journey or lack thereof
becomes a bit of a futile exercise
because we're not along for the ride to
see him achieve something great or at
least work towards achieving something
great we're here to essentially see what
he does when people with actual ambition
set their plans in motion and he needs
to either rescue them or prevent them
from reaching their goals now this is
not to say that passive protagonists
can't be interesting as well because we
have countless examples that prove
otherwise like Lord of the Rings Frodo
is your classic passive protagonist at
the beginning of the story he has no
reason to leave his nice cozy home at
all but eventually he makes the
transition to an active protagonist by
accepting the call to adventure which I
guess you could maybe argue that each go
does the same thing he has no reason to
seek out conflict but when someone is in
trouble he accepts the call that's fine
but you're very much starting out your
protagonist at a wild disadvantage
because you now need to move the story
and the world around them rather than
having them actively seek out the world
and the story like say the protagonist
of one piece for Luffy as he visits new
islands on his own personal quest to
reach the end of the grants line but
with a passive protagonist you need to
work that much harder because they in
and of themselves are not inherently
interesting nor are they wildly driven
to do anything and so a lot of heavy
lifting then gets put on auxilary
characters so to use the same previous
Lord of the Rings example this would be
the fellowship who assisted and even
pushed Verdot to
his goal especially Sam but each one of
them have incredibly strong desires of
their own and reasons for acting whereas
in Bleach ichigo's fellowship if you
will are more or less the same kind of
blank slates of ambition aziz or AHIMA
has no clear desire for the present or
vision for the future
Rukia is there another passive actor who
got caught up in fate / some sort of
female lead who is eventually pushed to
the side when Cooper realized it like
everyone else she has no driving force
chad is Chad and who even are you you
become irrelevant so quickly that I'm
not even going to talk about you and you
could say that for an awful lot of the
early bleach cast actually the only one
of the original bunch who has any sort
of depth whatsoever is Ishida who
actually has a strong desire to pursue
his heritage of being a Quincy rather
than following his father's desires for
him to become a doctor and this right
here it's so small but it's interesting
and it makes it ever so slightly more
compelling to follow Ishida but the
desire of an auxilary character alone is
not enough to sustain a long-running
series and so with a lack of driving
force for our initial main cast Kubo
solution to this problem was quantity
over quality and so the series became
perpetually flooded with bombardment
after bombardment of empty characters
who absolutely looked cool yes but once
the audience realized that they had very
little to offer then we needed to have
shiny new replacements come in to fill
the void now not every character was
like this obviously and I'd like to
point to kampachi as an exception
actually he is such a simple guy he
lives for battle and is always seeking
out the next strong opponent and once
again this isn't much but it's better
than what it Chico gives us but with
that said there is one point in the
story where Ichigo does come into his
own and it is during the soul Society
arc where we see him grow exponentially
as a character acquiring the strength
needed to defeat byakuya and save Rukia
this is when bleach was at its best for
me because this Ichigo had such
compelling conviction he may have been
desireless before and after now but
right at this moment his mission was to
declare war against the entirety of the
Shinigami to save a single person and
after taking on these absolutely
impossible odds he did it we watched him
struggle and emerge victorious if the
series had ended right here and now
I think bleach would probably be
remembered as one of the finest shonan's
ever put to page but it didn't and
instead this happened and look it's not
the middle finger but this is
essentially Aizen flipping off the
audience and saying that everything we'd
seen up until now was all for nothing
the struggle Ichigo went through and the
power he had gained rendered entirely
meaningless by one finger not only that
but the characters who had already been
rendered me
this by Ichigo and the arc in general
where further demoted to a level even
more than meaningless by this although
interestingly enough Aizen is another
one of those rare goal-driven characters
in Bleach he has a desire to stand atop
the heavens in place of the absent gods
or whatever it was it's vague and kind
of bad guy for the sake of being bad guy
but it's something else I rather
fascinatingly before Aizen leaves he
tells each girl that he is interesting
for a human this is a lie maybe not from
a character perspective of Aizen in
Ichigo but from writer to audience this
line is a big lie and it's because at
this point we'd already explored the
best at each go had to offer as a
character there was no room to grow from
here he'd done everything he wanted to
do which wasn't much but he did it and
then there's this finger staring at us
in the face going no no no no no no we
will contrive more reasons to get you
involved in this quote-unquote story and
look I can't speak for later arcs but
that's exactly what we're commando ended
up being Ichigo had to follow the exact
same story beats a soul society just for
the new female leading to stress because
his own personal ambition does not
further bleach he just has to react and
as a result his character rather
ironically succumbed to being a bit
Hollow and no amount of side characters
could fix that meaning that from this
moment onwards bleach was doomed but it
would be a grand a mistake to think the
characters are the only faulted Blake
here and the next thing I'd like to
touch on is the world now a lot of
people would sum up the section by
stating that there simply isn't one and
move on but that's not quite fair there
is something like initially being in
modern Japan which is definitely the
most detailed and fleshed out of all of
the world to present it in Bleach that
I'm aware of although it's owing in
large parts the entire history of Japan
rather than the ideas of a storyteller
and these lack of ideas can be seen
quite evidently when we abandon modern
Japan and leap into soul society they
supposedly mysterious spirit world ruled
by the most powerful Shinigami and I
mean the afterlife is one of those
things that has endlessly been explored
by humanity often coming up with
radically different dimensions beyond
anything possible in our own however
beyond its name Soul Society is
extraordinarily ordinary it seems to
consist of but a single city with a
beautiful blue sky
somewhat resembling feudal Japan but
does it there is no greater world we
have a single central point and then a
bunch of wasteland II area everything is
very visually flat with very few points
of aesthetic interest and I should note
that yes this does go to serve the style
of bleach quite well
Kubo is a very minimalist artists and
while lots of people including himself
actually may cite laziness for this
design show
it works for the most part and he is
able to create incredibly striking
artwork with characters and only the
barest of backgrounds but while this is
lovely it does suffer in regards to
prolonged storytelling when you don't
have a world acting as a character of
its own all of the weight falls onto the
characters themselves to carry the story
forward and with what we've already
examined about the characters we have to
play with in Bleach good god that is a
difficult task to put on them they
needed all the support they could get
and the world gave them nothing at all
to work with but it gets worse because
when this happens it reinforces that
what we know so far is pretty much the
extent of what we're going to learn
about soul society and the earth
dimensions and furthermore that there is
a further plane of existence out there
where Aizen and his posse will go to
twelve this is problematic because we've
already been exposed to two very
underdeveloped worlds and now we're
about to be plunged into a third and
look creating world is not easy it's a
disgusting amount of work that goes into
fleshing out their histories culture and
general society most of which we as
consumers only experience on a surface
level with that said come on we're
commando consists of absolutely nothing
incredibly vast amounts of absolutely
nothing it makes whole society look like
a Sistine Chapel of detail in comparison
and sadly this nothing represented the
death of the world of bleach where
commander gave the characters even more
nothing than usual to play against and
thus they were left entirely exposed as
the shallowly written figures they are
after which the series plummeted
but finally we need to explore the story
now this was never bleaches strongpoints
because art was always the selling
factor behind bleach and the story was
just kind of a thing that needed to come
along with the medium after starting out
as a monster of the week type of manga
bleach was soon streamlined into a very
simplistic story model for the soul
Society Ark which was rescue the girl
and yeah there were other things at play
and some interesting relationships that
go explored but there was just nothing
beyond rescuing Rukia here whereas in
other series there would always be a
greater story at play using arcs as
stepping stones towards that so for
example if we go back to one piece
everything the straw hats do goes
towards serving their ultimate dreams
everything Naruto does goes towards
eventually becoming the Hokage and
everything each go does is only to solve
an immediate problem and that
designation from Kubo makes it very
difficult to build an actual story
behind bleach and leaves it as a
moralist
improvised weekly soap opera if bleach
ever had a direction it lost it and
introducing a billion new characters is
not an effective substitute for story so
when soul society by father
stocke and seemingly only concern of the
entirety of the series at the time
wrapped up seeing this finger pop up was
very much a death sentence it's like
saying but wait there's more I haven't
thought about what more there is yet but
it's coming and from this moment on
bleach would just struggle to achieve
its previous glory with characters who
had no drive to be where they are no
world to support them and no story to
use either effectively and once again at
this point I should state that I have no
idea what happened to bleach after about
halfway through the work Amanda walk
from what I've heard it follows more of
the same and even had a semi-decent
story resurgence at one point but it
really doesn't matter because right
before this moment is where the series
should have ended everything before
aizen's finger is fine
yes I've called the characters a bit
shallow and the world quite flat but up
until now the series had not gone on
long enough for that to become a major
detriment now whether these characters
were then forced into further long-term
arcs that only went on to highlight
their lack of anything we'll each live
this new portion of its life on
character design alone which is a huge
credit to tee takubo he is definitely
one hell of an artist to continually
come up with such compelling designs
that he was no writer so as cool as
these characters look most of them
amount to nothing in the long run and
that is the tragedy of bleach a series
extended far beyond what its characters
world story and even author could
support it suffered a slow and
humiliating death not only falling from
the graces of anime and manga but being
kicked into the dirt which is a shame
because I used to love bleach even with
all the flaws I've mentioned everything
up until the end of Soul Society was
enough to captivate me as a teenager and
knowing where it eventually ended up
does hurt me somewhat as much as one day
I do want to go through the rest of the
series part of me just wants to leave
things as they are and maintain a strong
memory of the golden years this series
gave me moments that I will never forget
and for that I would like to thank Tito
Kubo and Shu Asia for allowing me that
in the first place
so no matter where you ended up here's
to the memory of bleach but that pretty
much does it for this discussion on
where did bleach go wrong if you enjoyed
this video and the content this channel
produce in general then please do
consider donating to the New World
review patreon because the support of
all of you amazing people is what
continues to make this channel possible
and of patreon isn't quite your style
then please do leave this video like
share or subscribe because it also helps
support this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time then please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan re takes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts on where bleach went wrong
this has been the new world of you and
I'll see you next time